I began to write this book on November
third,
2004.
I had come back to the states to give a
series of lectures on my last book,
which is on the subject of evil,
and I timed those lectures to coincide
with what I thought would be the
celebration of the end of the Bush
administration,
as you can imagine,
on November third,
2004 as I sat there drinking for double
Espressos,
a trying to get myself off the floor
enough to talk about evil.
I felt particularly disturbed about the
fact that people claimed they had voted
against the Democrats because the
Democrats were lacking in moral clarity
or they didn't have moral values.
I think particularly looked at from
abroad.
Although most Americans now see it that
way.
And administration,
that's reinstituted torture lied its way
into a war for which it can't even
provide for the soldiers who are losing
limbs and mental health center.
Uh,
it's hard to define as being morally
clear or having strong moral values.
But it seemed to me that I had two
choices.
One was to say,
okay,
all the people who voted that way have
simply been bamboozled by talk about
values and their real interests lie
elsewhere,
or I could examine what the faults on my
own progressive side war and to say what
have we been doing wrong,
and I think that it's true that secular
progressives in particular have had
trouble with moral language.
So I decided the thing that I could best
or most helpfully do really for my
country as somebody was philosophical
skills,
was to write a book reclaiming more
language for progressive
purposes.
A number of ways.
After the sixties,
the left was properly concerned.
I think that we had been to theoretical
ideological and that it was part of the
reason why the left had failed in the
United States was that we hadn't been
pragmatic enough and all of that was
true,
but the direction that the left turned
in was I think fatal.
Instead of talking about ideas,
they talked about interests and what you
had then was an interest based politics
which took what might have been the
greatest achievement of the civil rights
movement.
Which was to convince many people,
and I grew up in Atlanta,
I was a child in the middle of the civil
rights movement.
So it's a big part of my,
um,
my background is the belief that good
people have whatever background need to
stand up together for a universal rights
because there was an old song that says,
all men are slaves to our brothers are
free.
That's what I grew up believing.
All of that.
I'm also symbolized by many,
or at least civil rights leader.
A leader is Bob Moses who said,
this is not about black versus white
people.
It's about rational versus irrational
Instead of that spirit which animated
the early civil rights movement,
people began to think that politics was
about interest groups.
It was about black rights.
It was about women's rights.
It was about gay rights.
It was about,
as you see the mess that we are in now.
And I think it was a terrible mistake
because it took us back to the sort of
tribal politics that are actually pre
socratic were what everybody believes
is.
The bottom line is my group wants power
over your group.
This is not in the end,
a direction that can mobilize or inspire
anyone,
but it's the direction that the left
Wenton,
the right on the other hand went off to
build think tanks and it was very
interesting.
You had all kinds of a businessman
funding people to read Plato and
Aristotle.
Uh,
it's quite extraordinary that you had an
anti intellectual movement on the left
and an intellectual turn on the right
and they had a,
they were thinking in long terms and
they took over again.
That's a simplified view of what I think
happened,
but it's a piece of what I think went
wrong.
When you have conservatives,
and this is an international question by
the way,
it's not simply a national question.
You see the same thing happening in
Europe.
Conservatives are using the language of
universal values that the left is no
longer able to,
uh,
to the use without these horrible
quotation marks,
scare quotes.
I think another factor played a huge
role,
which is in 1989,
even those of us who hadn't been
communists and who had been
distinguishing for a long time between
what we call a real existing socialism,
which was not socialism as one wanted it
to be,
I think the collapse of the Soviet Union
made painfully clear to people who had
been wanting to avoid that,
that things in real existing socialism
were even worse than we had suspected so
that it was easy to take the line.
Many people who shared ideals that we
shared and had been willing to fight and
die for them had actually wound up
committing genuine crimes,
and if that's the outcome of people who
are willing to live and die for ideas,
maybe the world will be better off if we
did nothing.
I think it was understandable
conclusion,
not a correct conclusion.
I think we're still reeling from that
conclusion.
We're now talking about it.
You know,
this is a 18 years ago.
It's not very long that we've had to
rethink things were still in the process
of rethinking and I'm hoping to
contribute to that.